i have to bring up some johnny cash to  you because i was just listening to this  song he has a ton of songs about  trucking but one of them i was just  listening to um it's called all i do is  drive  where he's talking to an old truck  driver it goes  i asked him if those trucking songs tell  about a life like his  he said  if you want to know the truth about it  here's the way it is  all i do is drive drive drive  try to stay alive that's the course  and keep my mind on my load keep my eye  upon the road i got nothing in common  with any man  who's home every day at five all i do is  drive drive drive  drive drive drive drive so i got to ask  you uh same thing that he asked the  trucker  you worked as a trucker for six months  in in uh while working on the previous  book  um  what's it like to be a truck driver  i think that captures it  it really does  you